welcome back if you're ready to start
investing it's important to prioritize
trust and experience thanks to SMG Media
Group the sponsors of this segment that
trust and experience can be found with
Dr Steve Kaufman of Zeus companies Rocky
spoke to him to learn more
Dr Kaufman welcome to Las Vegas now
thank you thanks for having me Rocky of
course now introduce yourself to our
viewers this is our first time
okay well my name is Steven Kaufman and
I'm the founder of Zeus companies and
Juice companies is a commercial real
estate investing so we own commercial
real estate Investments we own real
estate debt and we own some Health Care
assets you've been investing for over 25
years I heard
almost 25 years don't I mean I don't
make don't age me I I'm investing for uh
for for 24 years I
okay bro so what part of the economic
cycle do you think we're in when it
comes to real estate
you know their their real estate cycle
is an independent Rocky of the overall
cycle they're actually totally related
we're heading into the part of the
economic cycle where it's a Slowdown
right before there's a huge uh hockey
stick or a huge increase and that was
what happened in 2004 5 6 and 7 before
uh the music stopped in 2008 and
um so we're we're in the 2003-2004 range
so we have until about 2026 ish and you
can quote me on that and and I'll
definitely come back and eat my words or
say I told you so if I'm wrong now with
that said it's important to know what is
a good or bad investment so how do you
go about you know giving people advice
for that
obviously it's a it's a personal
decision because families have different
risk tolerances but one of the things
that I like to say is that there are
three main investment criteria there's
safety liquidity and rate of return and
you're looking for the blend Rocky of
all three of those so what's the what
what is your interest what what's your
rate of return does that match your risk
level and if you're just getting started
it's very difficult to know where to
start or how to start and if you have a
401k at the company it that is a great
place to start to get the advice of that
financial advisor sometimes the advice
is biased to what they're offering
sometimes it's not I'm not saying you
think everything they say as the gold
standard but I am saying that's a great
way to start and the answer to your
question whether you start with
retirement funds or personal funds you
the the answer is you start as soon as
possible
um because the way wealth is accumulated
um is over time the most important
factor is going to be time
okay okay and what is one of the biggest
lessons you've learned in in this
investment game
um I for for I've learned lots of
lessons and I I think the biggest lesson
I have learned is
to not invest with someone who hasn't
done this before I can't let people
experiment with my money or my or my
friends money and I say friends I mean
the people who invest with us they're
trusting me and trusting our firm to
invest their money prudently and so the
biggest lesson I've learned is don't
risk your money
um letting someone else experiment
whether this idea is going to work or
not they have to have a very strong
proven track record that they can get
predictable results
thank you again to Zeus companies for
sponsoring this segment for more
information visit zeuslending.com Las
Vegas now we'll be right back
[Music]